is a social construct upheld by the bisi
in which they exploit the labor of
proletarian workers and cut down trees
to sell to society in a socially
acceptable way to make room for industry
this is all very silly you know freshman
year Marxism like certainly this person
whoever wrote this has never actually
read Carl Marx but has read maybe part
of the Wikipedia page about coral Marx
or copy tal or something this is good
because I could barely read so the last
part here is the silliest one she says
it's it's so that Society can cut down
trees to make way for industry they
don't just cut down trees in the
wilderness you get your Christmas trees
from tree farms and when they cut them
down they don't pave it for a parking
lot they grow more
trees in fact the tree Christmas tree
industry is responsible for there being
many more trees in the world because
they're growing them cuz it's a
sustainable renewable resource because
there's a customer out there to buy it
so that part's very very silly